[Music]
from the home workshop to the factory
floor the bandsaw is one of the most
popular power tools around it's called a
bandsaw because the blade is a metal
band with teeth that moves continuously
in a loop around two or three rotating
wheels
it can make straight curved and angled
cuts
[Music]
this is an industrial band saw designed
to cut wood aluminum and composite
material such as plexiglas
it can cut pieces up to 12 inches thick
and can divide a board up to 40 inches
wide into two equal sections
the tabletop tilts to a maximum 45
degrees for angled cuts
it's made of sturdy cast iron
the bandsaw manufacturer purchases it
from a nearby foundry
then uses a rotary grinder to make the
surface as we can see on the right
smooth and shiny
one of the saw's key components is this
lower bearing case it links the motor to
the lower of two cast iron wheels which
turn the saw blade
workers will later mount that lower
wheel on one end of the bearing case
shaft
[Music]
now on the opposite end of the shaft
they mount the drive pulley
the motor will rotate the drive pulley
turning the shaft and consequently the
lower wheel on the opposite end which
moves the saw blade looped around the
lower and upper wheels
those cast iron wheels meanwhile need a
rubber edge to ensure the blade moves
smoothly and without slipping
workers position a guide over the first
wheel then slip a rubber band onto the
guide
next they coat both the edge of the
wheel and the rubber band on the guide
with contact cement adhesive
then they carefully pull the rubber band
off the guide flip it over and press the
glued side against the glued surface of
the wheel
first wheel now has a rubberized edge
they repeat the same procedures for the
second wheel
in the meantime another department has
welded the bandsaw steel cabinet
after the cabinet gets a paint job
workers begin installing the various
components
among them the support assembly for the
upper wheel
[Music]
behind the wall on which they mount the
upper wheel down at the bottom and
protruding forward through the hole in
the wall they install the support for
the lower wheel
this support is the shaft of the lower
bearing case the side opposite the drive
pulley
after mounting the lower wheel they move
behind the wall install an electric
motor right below the lower bearing case
and link the two with a pair of belts
so now when the motor runs the pulley
rotates and the lower wheel turns
next they bolt in the tabletop
it tilts on trunnions pairs of mating
half circle cast iron supports
one attached to the table's underside
the other to the cabinet's table frame
now for the most critical part of the
assembly process
workers use this jig as a precision
guide to align the wheels
the wheels must be perfectly balanced to
keep the saw blade stable while it's
cutting
once the alignment's complete workers
remove the jig and loop the steel saw
blade around the two wheels
they adjust the blade to the correct
tautness by simply setting the tension
gauge to the width of the blade
[Music]
and finally the last step above the
tabletop they mount bearings which guide
the blade
[Music]
without these the blade would wobble or
drift offline due to the force of
cutting through the wood or other hard
material
now just a final check to ensure
everything runs smoothly and make
absolutely sure this bandsaw is up to
speed when it comes to cutting
construction materials
you